as the feds get closer things get
grosser
the probe in a hunter's questionable
income practices expands targeting his
ukrainian dealings
china and potential money laundering fox
news obtained emails in which hunter
asked that
keys be made for his new office mates
for a shared space with a chinese energy
firm's emissary
the mates his dad joe his fun uncle jim
and dr jill biden it's always good to
have a medical professional on staff so
this stinks like a day old diaper in a
red lobster dumpster
and it makes you wonder how much longer
the pathetic media will pretend
that there's nothing to see here let's
note the contrast between an
investigation
into someone they hate versus someone
they love
first the dossier the dossier has been
corroborated by the intelligence
community the dossier
in fact is far from bogus so far nothing
in the dossier has been disproved
increasingly it's the accurate dossier
what a bunch of dopes now hunter
we do know that this is a classic
example of the right-wing media
machine talking about the biden's
personal corruption a little bit about
hunter biden most of those charges
unverified
peddling baseless conspiracy theories
about joe biden
and his son as you know perfectly well
i'm a journalist and a reporter and i
follow the facts
and there has never been any issues in
terms of corruption
uh have you got to point out that you're
a journalist you're not
it's worth noting uh since the hunter
evidence is actually
real no one paid for a phony dossier and
then had the media pass it around like a
crack pipe
so it got re-verified by other jackasses
do you remember that trick you know if
one hack shares it with another
suddenly two sources are getting high
together they did this for four years
and still got nothing but dumber
meanwhile hunter
wasn't going rogue but working for joe
to secure
millions for him after 50 years of
sniffing hair except hunter didn't
factor in
joe not retiring whoops
now hunter's left holding the bag
wondering if jail gets seamless
no wonder obama asked joe are you sure
you want to do this
but sadly chyna now has joe over a
barrel
barrel filled with a lot of dirt and
what a relief for chi
after four years of dealing with trump
who had china's number
and fought on our behalf instead of
chasing popularity
no wonder china can't wait for the
inauguration neither can joe
i mean a lot can happen in six weeks we
went to kamala for comment
[Laughter]
so uh joe biden officially reached the
threshold
i think they're talking about the
electoral college and not actually
entering a room
do you want me to read this now some
breaking news california putting
president-elect joe biden over the edge
i was trying to do that he now has
passed 270 electoral college votes
yippee the next major step will be on
january 6 when congress has to confirm
the results this is so exciting
so jesse i love the media
mocking us for covering this too much
i think we have a do we have a tweet
from a cnn
media guys uh often consumed by fox
i don't know if we have it if we don't
i'll just keep talking and looking at
your beautiful hair
uh i love this part fox news led this
hour
with more fallout from hunter biden
investigation this is from brian stelter
who then says fox has a big problem
with portion control you know i'm just
gonna let that go
i'm gonna let that go jesse i'm not
gonna think
terrible thoughts i'm just gonna say
they had portion control problems with
the collusion
and everything else do you take it away
i'm gonna shut up
yeah they were gluttonous with collusion
got felt and i too am not gonna make any
fat jokes
i refrain from that in 2020 and i'm
gonna stick to it
um it is funny though so joe biden
shares his office with a chinese
communist for three years
so for three years he puts the key in
the door he opens the door and he walks
past
a chinese guy's office and the nameplate
says something
dong is the guy's name and then he just
walks to his office
and closes the door and sits down hey
hunter who's the chinese guy named dong
we're sharing an office with
oh nobody dad he's a chinese communist
he represents uh the exxon mobil of
china don't worry about it we're gonna
hold 10 for you
i mean how has a reporter not ask
joe hey joe did you ever go to your
office and while you were there did you
see
dong that would seem like a pretty
relevant question
besides the question which someone still
has not asked
have you ever met tony b so let me get
this straight joe we have hunter biden
son of the president
president-elect now i guess you have to
call him he goes over to a foreign
country brings home half a million
hides it from the irs spends it on
escorts
instead then gets pregnant at escort
at a dancer and then when she says can
you pay me some
child support he says no no no i'm broke
and he fights it
this makes don junior look like an angel
don jr turned over everything i mean he
sat for hours of deposition
handed over thousands of documents and
hunter and his
uncle james are stiff-arming
congressional
investigators and joe meanwhile says i
never talked to hunter about business
he wasn't making any money in china
everything was clean in ukraine
and this was all russia disinformation
all of that was a lie
greg who would have thought a lifelong
politician
with a history of plagiarism and family
grifting
could be so dishonest i don't know
um juan you uh got covid a virus
from china isn't that enough to impeach
joe biden
i don't know somebody should pay a price
though i'd be off for that because it's
hell
uh you know what i i've been listening
and i just think to myself
you know we don't know how bad this is
going to get for
uh hunter biden we just don't know but i
do
think i do think that president trump is
wrong to be going after bill barr the
attorney general
and saying oh he should have disclosed
this during the election
to my mind bill barr was acting in
accordance with the law
and so what you get now is president
trump who has his own tax problems and
whose kids have their own tax problems
trying to put the onus and the focus on
joe biden and hunter bite well there's
no indication that
joe biden has any role in this at all
and with regard to hunter biden i think
that
we all have to understand that hunter
he didn't look they talked about keys i
don't think that he was actually there i
don't know
that i just think it's wrong to take
shots of people involved in law
enforcement
i i don't think that was his office
jesse but it's uh i'll leave that
because i don't know for sure
but i'm just saying that it looks to me
like you know trump has no regard for
even an ally even one of his most
stalwart allies bill barr
because all that trump cares about is
getting reelected he didn't care about
the law or about how this country works
or the fact that we are
not a country of men but a country of
laws and it protects us all
very sexist juan men and women dana
this could be the biggest scandal of all
time
the biggest scandal of all time and the
media is ignoring it
worse than watergate you gotta believe
it you gotta believe it you know i do
think that the
biden transition team is dealing with
two heaping scoops
of problems going into their transition
one is that all of these other stories
the electoral college fight
the vaccine and also hunter biden in a
way
um that is masking the fact that they've
not had a great rollout
of their nominees for the federal
government
and in fact the progressives are quite
unhappy and
i think there's going to be some
difficulty going forward for them there
and then
you have to wonder if you're the
communications people for the biden team
every day you think how in the world did
i go through the whole day and not get
asked about this story
wow i must be a very lucky person
[Laughter]
you know emily uh you're you're an
attorney
hunter biden is an attorney uh what say
you
uh i hope you're not insinuating
something greg
uh i will say this so as we learn that
u.s attorney john durham
is expanding his team right in the
investigation into the russia
collusion origin probe it's a reminder
to us all
how long investigations take especially
ones
that span multiple jurisdictions and
aren't just about
tax affairs but are actually involving
complex foreign transactions and foreign
powers
so two things come to mind for me about
this in addition to that reminder
i've seen the government take five years
to investigate one count
of tax evasion so the two things are one
the duty and the power of the media greg
and dana to your points about it
and secondly the fact that while this
investigation these multiple
investigations play out
how crucial it is that there is a
highlight on
either conflicts of interest with now
president-elect joe biden or the
perceived
conflicts of interest with him in this
mean administration
because i think we have to know or
resign ourselves to the fact that
other than us the mainstream media won't
do it
um all right i think the real scandal is
my shirt
this collar is just too big for this
sweater
and i feel like i feel like the flying
nun just doesn't feel right today and
it's
affecting my performance